bientôt un nouveau permis de conduire en
france un permis de conduire qui
rétrécit l usage puisque chaque
infraction lent plus trad de quelques
points avec au bout du compte le retrait
pur et simple réunion cet après-midi du
premier comité interministériel du
redéploiement industriel
les ministres ont mis la dernière main à
leur plan de bataille avant le voyage de
laurent fabius en lorraine dans l'aube
france passe aux mains des japonais
après le bien des hésitations le
gouvernement a donné ce matin son feu
vert au groupe sumitomo
demain conférence de presse du patronat
français qui s'est fort peu exprimée ces
derniers mois ce soir le président du
cnpf nous suivons gattaz est l'invité de
ce journal
mesdames messieurs bonsoir le permis de
conduire se refait une jeunesse ce petit
livre est rousse qui prouve du moins en
principe que nous sommes capables de
conduire une voiture
ce livret va sans doute changer de
nature d'ici à la fin de l'année
prochaine il devrait céder la place à
une nouvelle formule au terme de
laquelle chaque conducteur disposera
d'un capital de points qui s'épuisera au
fur et à mesure des infractions commises
par son titulaire
c'est un peu la version moderne de la
peau de chagrin évoqué dans les contes
de fées cette décision a été prise à
l'issue d'un comité interministériel au
cours duquel d'autres mesures ont
également été retenu elles concernent
entre autres la formation des jeunes
conducteurs et la simplification du
permis moto tout de suite le détail de
ses propositions la procédure de
suppression temporaire du permis de
conduire va changer c'est le permis à
points
chaque conducteur disposera d'un capital
de points pour une période donnée à
chaque infraction grave l'administration
supprimera des points arrivé aux deux
tiers de son capital le conducteur
recevra un avertissement et subira des
examens médicaux son capital est puisé
plus de permis aux qui lui soit restitué
le conducteur devra faire la preuve de
son aptitude à conduire
c'est à dire examens médicaux pour de
conduite recyclage ce qui revient en
sommes à partir de nouveau le permis
éducation routière à l'école et conduite
accompagnée dès l'âge de 16 ans 40 % des
victimes d'accidents de la circulation
ont moins de 25 ans la formation des
jeunes conducteurs est donc déterminante
l'éducation nationale va prendre en
charge cette formation et il y aura même
des 1985 incarner d'éducation routière
pour chaque élève expérience pilote dans
les départements de l'essonne et des
yvelines
les jeunes de 16 ans pourront apprendre
à conduire dans des voitures
particulières à condition d'être
accompagnés d'un adulte et d'avoir
l'accord de leurs parents
fini qu'il faut être prudent et ne pas
chanter victoire en dix ans deux mâles
permis à 16 ans
non c'est une étape c'est un test qui va
être fait les résultats de ce test
permettant de dire dans quelles
conditions et sous quelle forme cette
expérience pourrait être généralisé la
lutte contre l'alcool au volant sera
intensifié les chiffres les données
statistiques mettant en évidence la
responsabilité de l'alcoolisme dans les
accidents de la route seront largement
diffusés or la campagne de
sensibilisation par des spots télévisés
sur le thème contrôler vous avant avant
d'être contrôlé la mise en oeuvre
d'éthylotests impuissant clairement le
taux d'alcoolémie permettra aux
personnes contrôlées de prendre
conscience plus précisément des
conséquences de leur consommation
d'alcool dès ce mois ci
les contrôles seront renforcés notamment
la nuit et le week end
contrôle de sécurité obligatoire dans
certaines conditions pour les
automobiles cette voiture vient d'être
acheté par monsieur pistier qui a eu la
prudence
un peu tardivement
faire effectuer un auto bilan j'ai un
bilan qui est ici essais marqués
véhicule dangereux à la circulation
après toutes les conclusions qui seront
tirées enfin bas de caisse complètement
mort moteur son tour sans user les peu
de même pas de même dimension fuite
d'huile dans tous les azimuts aussi bien
là le moteur que la boîte de vitesses
enfin c'est dingue c'est un véhicule qui
ne peut pas rouler c'est pas possible
c'est interdit c'est pour éviter cela et
pour éviter les accidents de la route
dus au mauvais état des véhicules qu'il
est question de rendre les contrôles de
sécurité obligatoires et cela dans trois
cas lors de la mise en vente d'un
véhicule de plus de 5 ans pour tous les
véhicules démunis de cartes grises et
enfin pour les véhicules gravement
accidenté des contrôles moins
systématique donc que chez nos voisins
comme la belgique ou la république
fédérale allemande ou les automobiles
sont soumises à contrôler tous les ans
ou tous les deux ans mais pour instaurer
des contrôles aussi systématique chez
nous il faudrait multiplier par quatre
ou cinq le nombre des centres de
contrôle
il y aura désormais deux permis moto au
lieu de trois le permis motocyclettes
légères accessible à 16 ans permettra la
conduite de moto de 80 centimètres cubes
de vitesse limitée à 75 km heure à 17
ans a même permis permettra la conduite
de moto de 125 centimètres cubes limité
à 13 chevaux
c'est à dire une vitesse maximale de 100
km heure environ
l'autre permis accessible à 18 ans
permettra la conduite de l'ensemble les
deux roues d'autre part seules les motos
de puissance inférieure à 100 chevaux
seront autorisés à rouler enfin les
normes de sécurité plus rigoureuse
seront exigés pour les casques
voilà ce que l'on pouvait dire ce soir
sur ce dossier qui nous intéresse tous
mais je vous le rappelle il ne s'agit
pour l'instant que deux propositions les
décision définitive devrait être prise
courant 1985 après un week-end plutôt
calme l'actualité sociale a repris ses
droits aujourd'hui avec toujours les
retombées du plan acier c'est ainsi que
le premier comité interministériel
chargé du redéploiement industriel
ce comité était réuni cet après midi
l'occasion pour les ministres qui y
participent de serre et les derniers
boulons de leurs plans acier à la veille
du voyage en lorraine de laurent fabius
jean claude renaud c'est bien sûr le
dossier lorraine qui était au menu du
premier comité interministériel consacré
au redéploiement industriel dans les
pôle de conversion sur les douze
ministres de ce super comité 3 s'était
fait représenter
mais pierre mauroy et laurent fabius
sont arrivés ensemble en tandem
ils se sont toutefois retrouvés face à
face autour de la table de réunion
c'est le premier ministre qui a présidé
mais c'est le ministre de l'industrie
qui est chargé
2préparer d'instruire et de mettre en
oeuvre les décisions de ce comité
et c'est bien sûr en tout cas laurent
fabius qui demain aura la tâche
difficile d'affronter les lorrains chez
eux
il sera en effet à metz pour rencontrer
les responsables politiques régionaux
ainsi que les représentants syndicaux et
patronaux
alors quelles décisions ont été prises
ce soir max gallo le porte parole du
gouvernement vient de nous dire qu'il ne
l'ait révèlerai pas il a simplement
confirmé qu'un 15e pôle de conversion
allaient être créés à fos sur mer
en tout cas si les décisions concernant
la lorraine ont été prises ce soir on
peut penser que le ministre de
l'industrie les réserves pour ses
interlocuteurs lorrain à metz demain
voilà bernard ce qu'on peut dire ce soir
à propos de ce premier comité on a
précisément jean-claude max gallo vient
tout juste de parler je vous propose
d'écouter donc ce qu'il a dit à la
sortie de ce comité interministériel
consacré donc au plan assez nous
écoutons monsieur gallo ce comité
interministériel a été consacrée
essentiellement au pôle de conversion de
la lorraine mais dans l'ensemble ces
comités interministériels sont consacrés
au pôle de conversion
il a été précisé notamment que 1 15e
pôle de conversion serait fixé à fos sur
mer
on a examiné les différents moyens
susceptibles de créer en lorraine des
emplois
la question de la décentralisation de
certaines administrations ou de services
d'administration centrale a été envisagé
et tout un ensemble de mesures mettant
en oeuvre à la fois la formation des
hommes je le répète la décentralisation
et la création des emplois ont été
examinés
ce plan a scié a aussi son mode
politique témoin cette petite phrase de
bertrand delanoë qui met en garde le
parti communiste le secrétaire national
du ps affirme en effet et je le cite
ou bien le parti communiste veut réussir
avec nous et il en aura les bénéfices
avec nous ou nous réussirons malgré lui
et il y laissera encore des plumes
ne seront pas répandre un état d'esprit
de défaites a conclu monsieur delanoë
qui a par ailleurs souligné que tous les
militants socialistes approuvait le
président de la république alors du côté
des communistes on a pourtant
semble-t-il choisi de mettre la [ __ ]
douce
andré lajoinie était un effet reçu tout
à l'heure chez pierre mauroy et en
sortant il a souhaité que la polémique
ne l'emportent pas sur le désir d'union
nous écoutons monsieur lajoinie il n'ya
pas contradiction entre notre soutien
notre notre appel à la mobilisation
populaire et notre loyauté et notre
engagement dans la majorité au
gouvernement
il sait il s'agit d'une action tout à
fait lié interdépendantes
non je vais vous montrer n'aurait pas
dans une polémique vis-à-vis du parti
socialiste l'heure est à l'union
la tâche qui nous est imparti aux deux
partis de la majorité c'est de d'opérer
le rassemblement populaire pour aller
l'avant alors que la droite se
mobilisent à droite finit bien il faut
s'unir
il faut s'unir évidemment pour
l'application des engagements confiance
en lui renouveler encore il ya quatre
mois alors ce n'est pas le moment de se
lancer dans des polémiques mais il n'y a
pas besoin de mise au net
j'ai dit que j'ai rappelé notre
politique tout à l'heure je crois
qu'elle est nette
l'état d'esprit est moins sera
semble-t-il du côté des jeunes
communistes dont le nouveau secrétaire
général jacques perreux a estimé tout à
l'heure que le sentiment dominant c'est
l'exaspération
l'heure est maintenant à la révolte et à
la colère pour les jeunes ans et des
secteurs en difficulté estime par
ailleurs monsieur purge sociale toujours
il s'agit encore des conséquences du
plan acier avec une manifestation à
fos-sur-mer des incidents se sont en
effet produits lors de l'ouverture de la
session extraordinaire du conseil
régional au cours de la réunion agitée
de son conseil régional le président
monsieur pezet a par ailleurs à fait
confirmé que deux navires allait être
commandés aux chantiers navals de la
seyne et de la ciotat deux autres
commandes ont également été confirmées
ce matin mais elle concerne dunkerque
cette fois où les chantiers navals norme
est de vous construire deux
transporteurs de produits chimiques ce
qui représente 4 millions d'heures de
travail anime plusieurs milliers de
viticulteurs manifestaient aujourd'hui
d'autres villes étaient d'ailleurs aussi
le théâtre de ces manifestations mais
cet anime
le plus grand rassemblement était prévu
les viticulteurs protestait une nouvelle
fois contre les règlements européens
relatifs à la production vini viticole
ils demandent notamment une alimentation
de la distillation pour se débarrasser
de leur excellent viticulteurs du gard
de l'hérault de l'aude jusque-là calme
et sérieuse s'achève devant la
préfecture
alors que la dispersion et décidé une
poignée d'autonomes mais les à la foule
provoque les forces de l'ordre
il y aura quelques incidents mais sans
gravité
pourtant vers 16 heures c'est au cours
d'un meeting que tout commença le maire
de nîmes d'abord qui lance un appel de
soutien unanime au monde des
viticulteurs à j allais fait une affaire
nationale qui s'impose à nous tous et
qui justifie un consensus
une solidarité et une démarche commune
d'ailleurs s'il en était autrement sinon
division cela ne pourrait que faire le
jeu de nos concurrents
j'ai dit écrit récemment que je n'étais
pas favorable à un élargissement à 12 de
la communauté économique européenne
car nous devons d'abord régler nos
problèmes à dix avant d'accueillir ces
deux nouveaux partenaires puis c'est au
tour du leader du syndicat viticole de
l'aude andré kaas qui fustige vertement
la politique menée par le gouvernement
d'étendre monsieur rocard il était temps
de prendre une telle décision
car depuis des mois nous sommes
orphelins d'un ministère de
l'agriculture où étiez vous monsieur k
au niveau de la communauté économique
domaine où étiez-vous dans les
négociations peut-être pensiez vous à
votre poste de président plutôt qu'à
votre poste de ministre de l'agriculture
mais jusqu'où iront ils la violence
certes sera employée s'ils n'obtiennent
et du gouvernement et de bruxelles les
mesures nécessaires pour contrer
l'arriver de l'espagne et du portugal
dans la marché commun d'allocs france
passe sous le contrôle des japonais
après bien des hésitations c'est
maintenant officiel le gouvernement a
préféré la proposition japonaise à celle
de michelin 1800 emplois devraient
disparaître dans les mois à venir
question marie mono d'allocs france
prend les couleurs du japon
ainsi en a décidé le gouvernement qui
avait le choix entre deux décisions
l'une européenne avec le concours de
michelin à l'autre japonaise après de
nombreuses réunions c'est monsieur saito
pdg de group sumitomo qui devient le
nouveau patron de dunlop france suite au
mot envoie un canot de sauvetage pour
dunlop mais nous ne pouvons pas sauver
tout le monde sinon le canot va couler
et nous avec
en ce qui concerne michelin d'autres
canaux n'est pas un bateau de guerre
contre la firme de clermont ferrand
notre bateau est celui de la croix rouge
qu'on ne tire pas dessus
nous prouverons que nous savons nous
aussi gérer la solution japonaise a donc
été retenu car plus intéressante sur le
plan social 1800 emplois seulement
seront supprimés sur 5800 notre part les
japonais ne sont pas trop gourmand sur
le plan financier elle s'engage investir
très rapidement quelques 300 millions de
francs
les représentants du personnel s'était
d'ailleurs rendu au japon
invité par le groupe sumitomo il ne
rejette pas la solution japonaise mais
la cgt à la paille côté favorable ou
défavorable la cgt elle demande au
gouvernement qui se prononce on n'a pas
choisi nous le repreneur yak subi comme
aujourd'hui où l'on prend et on discute
pour améliorer proposition séance
d'aujourd'hui
la décision intervient six mois après le
dépôt de bilan de dunlop france c'est
moluçon qui est le plus touché
car le département en poids lourds sera
fermée mais ce soir on se déclarait
soulagé par le chef de gouvernement
car on craignait le pire la situation
sociale en france et l'état de
l'industrie française ont suscité bien
des réactions parmi les syndicats ne
nous en sommes fait très largement
l'écho ici même pourtant un des
partenaires sociaux est resté
particulièrement discret pour ne pas
dire mais ces derniers mois il s'agit du
patronat français
son président me suivant gattaz est
l'invité ce journal
à la veille d'une conférence de presse
où le cnpf doit dévoiler les grandes
lignes de son action à venir
bonsoir monsieur gattaz tout de suite
une réaction à chaud sur le plan acier
vous n'avez jamais parlé de ce plan
goode et nous parlons pas du plh du plan
à chier mais nous parlons de la lorraine
et des activités qui sont à régression
en france va sont fréquentes
le drame de la sidérurgie drabo rennes
sont des drames grave pour la france
mais je voudrais simplement dire que dès
lors un des dix idéologie il y en a
beaucoup en france beaucoup plus qu'on
croit et la situation est peut-être plus
grave pour le croit en général je crois
que la situation de l'économie française
est à regarder avec gravité et je crois
que les français ont besoin aujourd'hui
on leur donne une voie à suivre
qu'on leur donne espoir et confiance car
aujourd'hui ils sont un peu perdus parce
qu'ils constatent alors justement
monsieur gaza c'est la politique de
rigueur amorcée par le gouvernement doit
vous satisfaire vous l'aviez souhaité à
plusieurs reprises
écoutez eux c'est vrai que la rigueur
est indispensable et est inévitable et
nous l'avons dit mais on ne peut pas la
prolonger trop longtemps sous cette
forme sans qu'ils aient des mesures
d'incitation à une sorte de sursaut
économique
si nous avons peu parlé comme vous
l'avez dit tout de suite c'est que
d'abord nous avons réfléchi nous en fait
une enquête une zone d'arrivée à trois
constatations
d'abord la situation économique est plus
grave qu'on dit le tissu économique se
déchirent les faillites augmentent vous
le savez deuxièmement le chômage empire
nous avons 58 chômeurs en plus rien
qu'un seul mois de février et surtout au
chômage des jeunes d'une extrême gravité
neuf cent mille jeunes au chômage depuis
de moins de 25 ans
non la moitié depuis plus d'un an vous
n'êtes pas les seuls à vous en
préoccuper du cheval dont j'aimerais
mais nous en occupons beaucoup croyez le
et troisièmement nous
l'impression que nos compatriotes sont
aujourd'hui désorienté perdu sans
objectif et se demande même pourquoi à
quoi vont servir leurs efforts et leur
sacrifice
nous pensons qu'aujourd'hui il faut un
sursaut économique si nous voulons pas
rester à la traîne des pays modernes en
particulier dans le domaine économique
il faut certainement aujourd'hui donner
des objectifs non et en particulier un
sursaut par l'investissement et par un
changement total de la fiscalité des
entreprises qui aident et motivante
répressive
alors qu'il faut une fiscalité
incitative sur tous les pays bas
notamment entre autres pays afin que ça
nous allons je vais demain au cours d'un
conférence de presse sur des
propositions précises dans le domaine
fiscal pour montrer qu'il est possible
sans un coup anormal pour notre pays de
relancer les investissements qui feront
les emplois de demain
alors c'est le gouvernement vous entend
et vous suit qu'est ce que vous proposez
un échange vous même sur écoute nous
disons que les chefs d'entreprise à bord
sont prêts à investir près il ya même un
frémissement aujourd'hui vous savez on
dit les investissements repartent non
n'exagérons pas il y a une volonté de
réussir de la part de tous les chefs
d'entreprise qui ne baisse pas les bras
mais nous n'avons pas les moyens
financiers il ya déjà de bonnes
intentions au croît il
mais surtout nous sommes prêts à lutter
contre le chômage avec efficacité avec
ses propositions précises des
propositions précises des deux mages les
frais mais je peux déjà vous dire que en
ce qui concerne par exemple les stages
déjà nous étions engagés à prendre trois
cent mille jeunes par an rien que par
des stages de formation alternée moitié
formation moitié en entreprise
malheureusement vous avez qu'une loi est
venue contrecarrer les accords que nous
avions pris avec les syndicats en
octobre ça ça va redescendre de 300000
alchimie et sachez déjà dramatique
deuxièmement nous allons négocier avec
les syndicats dans les semaines qui
viennent sur la flexibilité des
entreprises
et troisièmement demain je vais proposer
quelque chose de nouveau des emplois
nouveaux a contraintes à léger
c'est-à-dire des angles cas entre clans
nouveau comptage et il y actuellement en
france encore des emplois disponibles
mais chez emploi ils sont barrées par
des barrières administratives fiscales
sociales des contraintes de tous ordres
plus les contraintes psychologiques qui
existent également
il faut lever ces contraintes et nous
dijon qui lie actuellement quatre cent
mille emplois à créer mais très
rapidement en quelques mois avec cinq
conditions que je vous dis
faut faire des encore à comprendre
alléger pendant cinq ans il faut que ces
emplois ne change pas l'effectif
théorique de l'entreprise en particulier
ne n'augmente pas les seuils de 10 et 50
vous le savez troisièmement il faut que
ces emplois n'est pas de charges
sociales assises sur les salaires et
enfin confus sur ces emplois là les
supprimer pour des raisons économiques
si l'on était sans autorisation
administrative préalable voilà c'est à
ces conditions vous engagez donc à créer
400 mille quatre cent mille emplois
total engagement de votre part fin
d'engagement notre part nous
garantissons le succès ces mesures ont
d'ailleurs été expérimenté sous des
formes diverses en différents pays ils
ont toujours réussi
nous nous portons garants nous savons
créer 400 mille emplois nous savons
faire la ressent la relance par la
reprise de l'investissement qu'on nous
croient nous pensons être expert dans la
gestion d'une entreprise
mais nous le disons la situation est
grave il faut donner à nouveau espoir et
confiance aux français
merci monsieur gattaz merci une
commission d'enquêté parties pour
déterminer les circonstances dans
lesquelles neuf soldats français ont été
tués samedi au tchad près d'où seul ou
bas à proximité de la fameuse ligne
rouge des circonstances qui semble bien
difficile à préciser si l'on en juge par
les différents communiqués publiés
depuis hier l'une des raisons évoquées
par le ministère de la défense tient
torul même que rempli l'armée française
dans la région
un rôle que va nous expliquer gérard y
naît mais auparavant hervé brusini qui
est un djamena nous donne les dernières
informations qu'il est parvenu à
rassembler sur cet accident
3 automitrailleuses ouvre la marche
un camion de décès affirme le convoi
prêts à intervenir en cas d'attaqué
aérienne libyenne c'est une unité de ce
type qui a subi ces pertes de 9 morts et
six blessés
samedi dernier les unités françaises
engagées dans l'opération manta se sont
adaptées à la nature désertiques du
terrain en plus des postes fixes de
petites unités d'une vingtaine d'hommes
avec des véhicules légers sillonnent le
désert
c'est ce que les militaires de la force
mentale appelle la nomadisation ils
patrouillent toujours en deçà de cette
ligne rouge de défense qui coupe le
tchad en deux pour l'état majeur c'est
de dire impliquent une mobilité accrue
la nomadisation consiste pour une unité
élémentaire ou un ce groupement a quitté
sa base et pendant quelques jours à se
rendre de point en point et qui ont pour
but de couvrir la zone de renseigner sur
un point ou dans une zone sans engager
le combat ce n'est pas leur vocation
mais étant capable car très armés de se
défendre de se replier et de faire
passer le renseignement pendant une
dizaine de jours chacune de ces unités
autonomes patrouille dans des zones où
il est impossible de maintenir des
postes fixes un engagement
supplémentaire pour la force mentale
depuis deux mois
ces patrouilles s'effectue avec des
forces d'hissène habré donc un risque
accru pour nos soldats
certes les unités françaises ont reçu
l'ordre de se retirer en cas d'attaqué
et pratiquement le pourront elles en
plein combat remaniement ministériel au
vatican un remaniement considéré comme
très profond puisque jean paul ii a
nommé 18 nouveaux responsables parmi
lesquels l'archevêque de marseille
le cardinal etchegaray et puis surtout
le pape a renoncé à s'occuper de la
gestion de l'état du vatican il a confié
au cardinal casaroli le mandat de
s'occuper de cette fonction temporel le
saint-père entend ainsi pouvoir
consacrer tout son temps à ses
responsabilités spirituel c'est une
décision sans précédent
françois mitterrand était en grande
bretagne aujourd'hui très exactement
près d'oxford où il inaugurait avec la
reine elizabeth le fameux jet
il s'agit du plus puissant appareil de
recherche consacrés à la fusion
thermonucléaire
l'occasion pour le chef de l'état de
rappeler que tout ne va pas si mal en
europe et que l'europe scientifique au
moins fonctionne bien
françois mitterrand n'a toutefois pas
rencontré margaret thatcher occupé par
ailleurs l'entente cordiale dont on
célèbre le 80e anniversaire n'a donc
rien changé à la fête
philippe harrouard l'europe du 21e
siècle
nous y sommes déjà ici à tulle armes
près d'oxford où ce matin la reine
elizabeth le président mitterrand on
inaugurait le pjak
derrière ce nom fut pour un projet
européen considérable d'une expérience
thermonucléaire menée par 12 pays
les 10 de la communauté plus la suisse
et la suède qui devrait permettre de
produire l'électricité du suture l'enjeu
de ces grands projets européens ce lac
et de la croissance économique de demain
devait préciser monsieur mitterrand qui
a cité l' airbus
le programme plus pour les technologies
de pointe et le développement des
réacteurs rapide
à travers ses réalisations apparaît
l'émergence d'une communauté
scientifique européenne ici très
largement représentés autour de pôles
d'excellence ouvert sur l'extérieur
exposé le sud une bonne chose à la
compétition internationale
c'est dans ces lieux d'accueil qui sont
aussi des lieux de formation pour nos
jeunes chercheurs que se crée peu à peu
une conscience commune
c'est donc là aussi que l'europe se
construit après cette inauguration le
président mitterrand est rentré en
france sans rencontrera mme thatcher qui
n'avaient pas pu dégager un moment dans
son emploi du temps
finalement les présidents n'ont pas
évoqué avec les eaux britanniques
nos difficultés de l'europe la journée
aura été a pris uniquement sur une
europe qui marche est plutôt bien leur
offre scientifique et technologique
mais après tout qui s'en prendre à ces
la liste d'opposition qui a finalement
gagné l'élection municipale de cette il
s'agissait de la seule ville remportée
en mars par l'opposition dont les
résultats avaient été invalidés pour un
défaut de procédure l'opposition s'est
donc maintenue à l'issue de ce troisième
tour
paul amar nous brosse maintenant le
portrait du vainqueur et décrit les
raisons de son succès
le vainqueur yves marchand 38 ans
une victoire écrasante pour ce jeune
homme ambitieux et sans complexe au
modèle reggane
son credo l'anticommunisme
la première chose quand même que les
sétois ont dit aujourd'hui c'est que la
chape de plomb communistes qui avaient
pesé sur pendant 24 ans devait sauter
ils ont dit oui à la liberté il ne
pouvait le dire que massivement une
seule cible le pc une campagne offensive
et musclé un ton très politique
polémique même et des adeptes dans
toutes les couches de la population
il est conduit en voyou j'aime pas la
dictature
que l'on soit de droite ou de gauche
j'ai mal à la démocratie
républicain moi je souffrirais public
est mort conséquence inévitable un
clivage de la vie dans deux camps
irréductibles droite contre gauche une
gauche également unis elle avait oublié
ses divisions
mais aussi son sigle impossible
d'identifier ces affiches comme si elle
voulait se démarquer du gouvernement
elle le confirme implicitement après
l'échec
je passe donc nous subissons le
contrecoup d'une situation de
mécontentement qui réelle du produit
national
autrement dit un vote sanction contre le
gouvernement un vote révélateur le
paysage politique a bien changé en
province fini les scrutins dit
apolitique le débat traditionnel sur
l'urbanisme les activités locales se
transforme désormais en véritable
bataille idéologique qui profitent
aujourd'hui à l'opposition l'a si bien
compris qu'elles n'hésitent plus à
s'attaquer aux symboles de la gauche
yves marchand le nouveau maire de sète
ne regrette pas d'avoir fait des
baptisés la salle léon blum pour lui
donner le nom d'un enfant du pays
georges brassens
les sétois ne l'ont pas désavoué mais
georges brassens lui aurait-il approuvé
un nouveau rebondissement dans l affaire
dite des irlandais de vincennes l'un des
officiers présents lors de l'arrestation
de ce qui avait été présentée à l'époque
comme de dangereux terroristes
cet officier le commandant bout
reconnaît avoir trompé la justice il
accuse le commandant christian prouteau
conseiller technique à l'elysée de lui
en avoir donné l'ordre
c'est le journal le monde qui révèle
cette information dans son édition
d'aujourd'hui
une affaire qui relance un dossier déjà
extrêmement compliqué et polémiques
albert du roy
oui cette affaire est empoisonnée depuis
le départ quasiment à l'été 82 lorsque
le président françois mitterrand après
le drame de la rue des rosiers décide de
prendre lui-même la responsabilité de la
lutte antiterroriste il nomme ses côtés
à l'elysée le commandant de gendarmerie
prouteau à partir de ce moment là tout
dérape on arrête trois terroristes
d'irlandais à vincennes et au fil des
mois on apprend premièrement que ce ne
sont pas des terroristes
deuxièmement qu'ils ont été arrêtés dans
des conditions illégales donc
scandaleuse
troisièmement que des responsables de la
police et de la gendarmerie ont tenté de
travestir la vérité sur cette
arrestation
aujourd'hui les chevaux romont
jusqu au commandant prouteau donc
jusqu'à l'elysée et on peut être sûr que
le feuilleton n'est pas terminé
ce qui est le plus frappant dans cette
histoire c'est qu'elle inspire une
réflexion que l'on a pu déjà faire au
moins 20 fois
chaque fois que pour raison d'état un
service officielle ou un responsable
politique a tenté de dissimuler une
vérité le secret se retourne finalement
contre ceux qui voulaient se protéger
grâce à lui faut-il rappeler l'affairé
ben barka le scandale de la villette
l'assassinât du pres de breuil vous l'
affaire des diamants de bokassa le
secret n'a servi qu'à une seule chose à
faire durer des années
un climat de suspicion qui aurait pu
être dissipé en quelques jours
à une condition de reconnaître tout de
suite l'erreur ou la bavure de départ
bref la raison d'état est non seulement
très souvent immoral mais elle est aussi
presque toujours inefficace et de la
politique nous passons billard avec pour
terminer trois des plus beaux coups qui
ont conclu hier aux pays bas les
championnats du monde de billard des
coupes sont à la fois beau surprenant
est impressionnante de virtuosité
auribeau dit qu'elle un premier coup
joué par le futur vainqueur à noter que
les lignes qui sont dessinés sur le
tapis sont fictives et le belge
faidherbe félicité par le troisième le
français coréen qui va jouer son dernier
coup cela paraît facile les souris
parvenir il convient de bien préparé son
coup
n'est ce pas monsieur
bravo bravo monsieur le champion et pour
le plaisir de re voyons ralenti ce
superbe
la météo maintenant avec brigitte sy
monitor et sans plus tarder un coup
d'oeil sur la carte de demain le matin
brouillard sur la moitié nord brume sur
la moitié c'est l'après midi beau temps
à l'ouest beau temps au sud
beau temps sur la corse mais toujours
alternance de nuages et d'éclaircies sur
le corner 9
les températures sont en hausse de 10 à
12 degrés sur la moitié nord de 10 à 18
degrés sur la moitié sud
demain mardi 10 avril le soleil se
lèvera 7h09 se couchera 20h35
nous fêterons les super forme ce journal
aux environs de 23h vous retrouverez
avec l'eau demain 12h45 daniel bilalian
18h30 c'est la vie jean-claude allanic
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée
et je vous retrouverai demain à 20h
bonsoir